okay so the early roman calendar
it consisted of 10 months and had 304
days
okay so only 304 days so the year was a
squeak so yeah so the two months
they lost two months i hope one of those
i hope they didn't lose august that's my
birthday yeah that's me and chrissy's
birthday yeah
with each new year beginning at the
vernal equinox i mean mike's using big
words here
and mike's also checked out right now
[ __ ] texting
i thought you were texting it too yeah
okay um
over the centuries the calendar fell out
of sync with the sun
yeah because they [ __ ] up demand why
because there weren't chinese kids
around back then to do the man
let's look out they left a copy over
they left it up to a bunch of [ __ ]
greek
inbred incest [ __ ] to do the math and
they those greek kids can't do math yeah
but they can't but the chinese kids can
do to man but guess what everything
roman is based on greek and listen and
everything in the world
is based on the roman so a good people
live in
everything yeah because yeah even the
[ __ ] astronomer that julius caesar
used to [ __ ] consult with to figure
out his [ __ ] calendar
was a greek kid named something jairus i
think it was [ __ ] a jairus boy
yeah it's just what it is yeah his name
was panayoti yeah i loved it i loved it
yeah the way giannis [ __ ] yells about
how mighty the greeks are he drives a
ford fusion yes look at us
that's just what it is okay um so the
julian calendar was introduced by julius
caesar who was a great [ __ ] kid
julius caesar with a great haircut he
had a lot of good ideas
he had a lot of good ideas so julius
caesar he wanted to solve the problem
and he consulted with prominent
astronomers and the mathematicians of
his time but again they weren't chinese
kids
there weren't gay kids or chinese kids
so you can't have good astronomers or
good mathematicians if you don't have
the gays in the chinese
the gays [ __ ] love signs that what
sign you are and the and the chinese
level
yeah some guys like to bug chase too
yeah it's what yeah
you're a [ __ ] bug chaser i was i'm a
reformed bug chaser
yeah okay so um
we've had many calendars we've had many
calendars other than the
the julian calendar which we use now um
we've had the uh the babylonian calendar
gross uh hebrew calendar yuck egyptian
calendar gross
greek calendar gross chinese calendar
gross yeah yeah um
yeah yeah like always is a catholic
church that came in here and messed
everything up
because everybody was okay they were
okay with this
you know with with uh with the year
being a little longer or whatever
and then the the catholic church is the
one that came in
and they said hey we don't like this
because we want to make sure
our religious holidays are celebrated on
their actual days
like it matters like it [ __ ] matters
yeah so all right in october 1582 pope
gregory took it upon himself to resolve
this problem and that's when the
gregorian calendar came to be
yeah so right now what is it it's a
combination of the julian and gregorian
it's a combination of all uh like the
hebrew
the chinese uh so it's kind of like
evolved it's
we have a trans calendar yeah in a way
our calendar is trans
no it's not trans it's it's a calendar
it's a one it's a calendar
it's not different it's not trans it's a
calendar okay yeah yeah
yeah all right listen that was actually
a great [ __ ] moment right there that
was about calendars
so listen we really hope you enjoyed
that episode whatever it was about this
is just a stock thing that we're taping
on to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.com where things get
really wild